please welcome Kristen Bell and Rico
Kalin Tony Jason Doering
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome welcome all of you to the
program thank you for being here and I
want to start with you yesterday was
your birthday so happy birthday my house
because I like birthdays so much and I
warn people about my birthday a month in
advance because I like really like being
alive and so celebrating that is great
and there's a rule in my house tax made
that it is your birthday until you
decide it's not your birthday anymore
and I'm done I've gone well into
September I get to pick what we need I
get to pick what we watch everyone
follows my rules that's right right okay
well you eventually get fatigued right
you I'm still celebrating yes yes we're
all very happy for you and the first
question is for you
the Veronica Mars character she is I
think part of her appeal after all these
years is that she just doesn't care what
other people think of her and I think
that that's this amazing trait that she
has it's a trait I wish I had do you
yourself you know I know you a little
bit but I don't know do you have that
trait nah everybody knows I'm a super
codependent I like I ache to be like
that and that's to be honest why I
wanted to put her out in the world again
because I think really this is the way
my husband lives like it doesn't matter
what other people think about you it
matters what you think about you is the
most important way to live
I'm not there yet but I do I'm like I
wanted to do this character ganks I
wanted people to say what would Veronica
do and think about her although she has
infiltrated me in a lot of other ways
you mean you solve crimes on the side I
haven't solved any yet I'm on an app
called next door and it's really fun you
guys it's like do you know it it's like
your neighborhood drama and people get
in fights it's so much wait how does it
work you tap on the app and it tells you
what's going on in your neighborhood
public masturbation like make you Joker
I don't want that out like it might be
like a masturbation is that like a
meet-up it's like anything once I
followed a girl for like two blocks
because she didn't have a doggie bag for
her dog and then the guy who's posting
it's like don't worry I followed her for
two blocks and as the people reading it
were like you're psycho stop following
her yeah it sounds disturbing on that
app I haven't solved any crimes but I
did I did once go through my neighbor's
trash because I did have a I had a good
reason I had a good reason to do so and
I I just like Veronica I'll only
participate in legal stuff I looked it
up
it is technically Lea you're allowed to
legally do that you can go through your
neighbor's trash a Supreme Court case
yeah yeah backtrack and I think there's
more important [ __ ] for the supreme
court to be doing right apparently
they're looking good they got that and I
didn't I didn't find anything but I
don't regret it all right